- I think that we love this though.
You love hot dogs, and I love hot dogs.
- I do love hot dogs.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I do, yeah.
- [Kelly] Why, when did
this start, this passion?
- [Brie] Oh gosh, yeah.
When did my love with affair
with the hot dog begin?
Well, I've always loved hot dogs,
but my best friend, Courtney McBroom,
who's also the food consultant on...
Oh yeah, you can see it right there.
- [Kelly] In Lessons in Chemistry.
- [Brie] Yeah, food consultant
on Lessons in Chemistry.
She started, she's the president
of the Hot Dog Appreciation Club.
And I'm a proud member, obviously.
- [Kelly] Nice, nice.
- Yes, and so this is segued into
a hot dog appreciation festival.
That's once a year at my family's house.
My step dad dressed as a hot dog.
It's a lot, but it's, it's a
really great, it's super fun.
Oh yeah you can see it all going down.
- [Kelly] So I hear you have
a debate with that fanny pack.
Get it.
- [Brie] Oh no, we're gonna get into this.
- I hear there's a debate, yeah.
- Okay, let's get into
the heart of the issue.
- If the hotdog is a sandwich
or if it's separate, if
it's a hot dog, it's not.
- [Brie] I think a hot dog is a hot dog.
I think to say that it is
a sandwich is blasphemy.
But Courtney thinks that it's a sandwich.
And it's very hard to argue with someone
who is the president of a
Hot Dog Appreciation Club.
It's like, why am I fighting reality?
I don't know, it's kind of fun.
- You know what's funny is I don't,
I've never thought about it.
Maybe y'all have, but I've
never thought about it.
But it is bread with meat in between.
- [Brie] I know, but it's connected,
and that makes all the difference.
(audience laughing)
- Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
But what about a subway sandwich?
Like a, you know, that's a sub.
It's connected.
Am I blowing your mind right now?
- It's not, it's not connected,
it's not connected, it's not connected.
(Kelly laughing)
- All right, no.
- I just wanna see.
- You're totally right.
- Show of hands.
How many people, I won't be
offended, I'm just curious.
How many people think a
hot dog is a sandwich?
See, the people who say no-
- [Kelly] We're alone.
- [Brie] are emphatic that it's a no.
And we don't even really know why,
but it's just wrong.
But I'm very proud of the like
five people that stood
strong in their belief
that it's a sandwich.
- [Kelly] Yes, thank
you, you stood with me,
we were alone on an island, but it's okay.
(Brie laughing)
I never thought about it before.
And then I was like,
well it kind of is like
a sub sandwich, kind of.
- [Brie] It's thought provoking.
- Yeah.
- It's thought provoking for sure.
- [Kelly] Thought provoking, well...